but you know a lot of people sit in
their spanish class at the local
community center for
years and don't get as far as you do in
all these different languages that
you're dabbling in so
it's you got to have a goal but also i
think a lot of people are pretty passive
in their in their language learning you
know they go to the class and whatever
the teacher brings to the class and
tells them to do that's what they do and
and it's just like they're treading
water they never get anywhere so so you
know yeah you may not be c-2 but to get
to a2 in all of those languages is
nevertheless quite an achievement
yeah a2 is you can't talk about politics
or something crazy but yeah too you
pretty you you you're conversational you
can have fun you know
so it's not it's always about trying to
get to
this high c2 level you don't have to set
yourself but i mean it's good if you
want to do that right but
you know everyone's goal is different so
it really all depends on the person i
mean what i like to do is i would like
to get to the point where i can pick up
my uh my podcast in the morning in
arabic or persian and understand most of
it
just by listening just by listening
that's kind of where i want to get to
because i don't have that many people to
talk to
yeah i like to be able to listen to
stuff and understand it like right now
in russian if i get something if there's
a i follow different people on twitter
in russian and ukrainian polish and i
can understand what they're saying i'm
happy
i can't possibly maintain conversations
with you know
people you know in different languages i
don't have that uh yeah you don't have
that so
that's fine too like
that's perfect like if you you want to
just learn how to understand exactly
because of that there's nothing wrong
with that and if you have good
understanding and you're put in a
situation where you have an opportunity
to speak the speaking comes pretty
quickly i i find oh yeah oh yeah
absolutely
so so you're in arizona where are boats
in arizona uh phoenix i'm here for you
yeah yeah so we're in palm springs in
the winter my wife and i if you're moms
you do a lot of traveling you were just
in california weren't you i am in
california i am are you in california
right now yeah yeah yeah i mean oh
springs yeah yeah
oh you just said you report
okay
yeah doesn't look like vancouver
no
no my wife doesn't like it when it rains
all the time i don't mind i play
old-timers hockey goes cross-country
skiing and i'm quite happy in vancouver
but she doesn't like it
so we're down here for the winter
yeah i i um
when i when i tell people about because
i got a lot of people uh older people um
also and i always use you as an example
i
like they say well i don't know if i
want to learn i'm too old
and i said well
you know you need
you too old i i say well
i know someone who who's up there and
he's still learning languages so you
need to check him out uh for some
inspiration because you know that's that
that right there a lot of people they
even even someone that's 30 yeah
believe that it's too late to learn a
language they think that they're too old
oh i'm 30 years old and you know what
what should i do i'm like you know i'm
38. i'm about to be 39 right and i'm
still learning i just started learning
languages until i was 18. so
it's really not the age but i think it's
a
uh what do you call it
it's a a misconception yeah i mean this
so-called neuroplasticity we retain our
neuroplasticity and and the more
languages we learn the better we get
uh but interesting you didn't start till
you were 18 like uh so when you were
because obviously if as a young child
you hear different languages i think
that makes the brain more flexible
uh if you've only had one language then
it's a little more difficult to break
out of that but then once you start
learning more language then the brain
becomes more flexible but you know on
youtube like there's all kinds of
different people so
somebody said oh you know when you're
old uh you can't learn languages so i
went back and said what what is old to
you what is old yeah and the person said
40.
40.
yeah 40. yeah that's great that's great
it's great that you uh
that you're on youtube doing that
because a lot of there's a lot of people
out there they see stuff and they see
they get inspired and they want to learn
but they they have second thoughts
because they're reluctant because they
feel that it's going to be difficult for
them because they're because of their
age so when they see someone that's up
there doing that then that inspires them
even more and giving them more belief
yeah you know that they can do it and i
think that you need those there's so
many things that that get us going like
certainly
you know if you have a session where you
go and speak to someone in khmer and you
do it well
then you want to go back and study more
khmer right like that's right a sense of
achievement there but the other thing is
just to see people and i think to see
you know you're essentially a model
initially a monolingual
anglophone north american
uh and you're out there speaking all
these exotic languages
uh and and even more so like there's
there's not as many african-american
polyglots like there's more uh you know
and so that's another uh perhaps i don't
know if you have that inspires other
african-americans who might not see
themselves as potential polyglots
although i tell you when we have our
polyglot conference in montreal
yeah
there's
got to be quite a number of uh both
african canadian african-american
polyglots that show up that speak five
six seven languages
so i'm i'm not sure that the african
americans are underrepresented in the
polyglot community but certainly yeah
i'm sure you're an inspiration
yeah it's definitely uh yeah it's always
someone that looks like you that's doing
something like that is always inspiring
exactly you know you see
you know that's i think that's important
also
yeah yeah and and and i think sometimes
we think it's
like i saw this i spoke with this other
with this fellow uh he calls himself
xiaoma
who has a channel and he goes and talks
to people and so-called you know like
level up type thing and
and oh here's this white guy speaking
chinese or or you know here's his
african-american or black guy speaking
like there's nothing inherently strange
about
a white guy or a black guy speaking
anything
any more than it's
strange that an asian looking guy speaks
english like we can learn any language
it's not related
i think it's when it comes to that type
of stuff i think it's uh because it's
more of a media thing and an in an an
image right so that people look at they
associate that with the image and then
so
like um
anybody can learn language it doesn't
matter where you from it doesn't matter
what color you are any language but i
think it at i think when it comes to
like racial stuff i think it's more of
image and
more of um
media stuff is how they portray certain
things so it's like when you see this
person doing this you don't really it's
like wait hold on that's not normal
you know because this this is contrary
to my perception right so i think it
comes
at the end of the day it's perception
that's what it is but
anybody can learn language it doesn't
matter where you're from i mean anybody
i mean that's that's
and and any language like there's
nothing particularly exotic like to us
asian languages are exotic but they're
not exotic to them
and if if we had been as
been born there or whatever we'd speak
those languages naturally i mean there's
nothing
no language is is this
i mean quechua like i was in uh
cusco machu picchu and uh so they speak
quechua there it's a great place to go
to because
they are very proud of their traditions
there
and so while they speak spanish uh they
all speak quechua
and and i think sketch was probably the
most widely spoken
no maybe
i think guarani and paraguay which is
the national language but in peru is not
in lima but in in cusco they all speak
quechua
and uh if you were to try to learn
question you'd learn ketchup and ketchup
just gotta there's another language over
in spain
uh it's uh what is that not catalan oh
basque
the best language
bat no no no it's not bad there's
another one that i see come up very
often people say you should try this
lane it's not basque it's not catalan
well is it gallego
but gallegos is almost like portuguese
that's spoken there and um
i mean all the languages that are more
or less you know latin based languages
are more or less similar whether it be
catalan gallego or whatever but and of
course basque is totally different oh
there is um no no they're either related
to the southern french
languages
or related to spanish portuguese i guess
other than basque i'm not aware of
anything
exotic there
yeah
anyway hey listen if you uh are coming
out this way to palm springs in the
winter let me know
and uh wait wait so wait the winner so
what is this when are you going back to
canada i am going to um
i actually have to my son mark and i are
going to japan
you know here's the deal my son played
professional hockey for 10 years uh six
years in europe and three years or so
three four years in japan
he's now 49. the team that he played for
has invited him to come back and play in
two games
so he's going to go there and
practice with them for a week and then
play in these two games so i'm going
over as well so i'm flying back to
vancouver on the
12th i think of march and we fly over to
japan
for nine days then i come back then i
come back here and then we go back to
vancouver on the 18th of april
and that's it and then i don't come back
down here until november oh okay and so
typically i spend four or five months of
the year my wife and i spent four or
five months ago your son lives in
california no no no he lives in
vancouver he lives okay
okay he lives in vancouver everybody
lives in vancouver it's just that my
wife and i winter down here in palm
springs
to avoid the wet season
yeah it's beautiful i mean arizona's
pretty much california y'all got more
people coming here we have more and more
people coming here from california it's
crazy
yeah california place everywhere like
they're they're moving over here oh yeah
yeah yeah no that's uh because the taxes
are lower and the costs are lower and
stuff
yeah nice weather and yeah there's a lot
of a lot of things to do it's it's it's
pretty much as similar to california i
mean i think so i mean i've driven i've
driven from palm springs to phoenix and
it's pretty flat
deserty type climate yeah yeah
okay well listen i hope you don't run
out of languages and
i don't know when i when i reach your
age we will have to see when i reach it
well yeah
you might run out you got a few you got
35 years to go so
we're going to we got to start speaking
with animals man
learn animal language
okay
we'll figure something we'll figure
something out as long as it's fun we
keep going the same here exactly okay
well it's always a pleasure to talk with
you mr my pleasure
moses i'm steve by the way even though
even though i'm old i'm old but i'm
[Music]
you